when the bough breaks stars Morris
Chestnut and Regina Hall as a couple who
are trying to conceive a baby but are
unable to because of medical reasons so
they look for a surrogate mother enter
Anna Walsh a very nice sweet young girl
who says all the things this couple
wants to hear and they agreed to
conceive a child with this woman as
their surrogate and of course as you
might expect if you've ever seen any
film like this she becomes a psychopath
and now we have a romantic thriller when
it comes to movies like this I like to
look at the facts I tend to be a very
naive person when it comes to filmmakers
and writers and actors and actresses
because I have such a deep love for film
that I tend to just think everyone is
the same like everyone who makes movies
just loves the art of filmmaking
everyone who takes a role just loves the
art of acting everyone who writes a
screenplay just they have such a passion
for writing and that's why these movies
are made for us that's not always true
some movies really are just made for the
sole purpose of making money I call
those movies conveyor belt movies they
might as well have been assembled by a
machine and they're currently being
processed out of the conveyor belt for
the audience's to eat up and for the
studio to make some money back and when
the bough breaks is absolutely one of
those movies this movie is designed to
make money and that's it it has
attractive lead actors a pg-13 rating a
plot that has been recycled ever since
fatal attraction and done 10,000 other
different ways and it can be made for an
extremely low budget that they can
probably make back in its opening
weekend alone I like Morris Chestnut I
had the privilege of meeting the
gentleman a few years ago I got to
interview him for his show legends on
TNT he was charming he was funny he was
likable he was a nice guy he's capable
of much better roles than this and I
really would like to see him in a better
film here's some more facts for you
Screen Gems is the company that's making
this film they also made the movie
obsessed with Beyonce and Idris Elba
another romantic theme thriller about
some form of obsession that eventually
ends in some form of violence
they also made no good deed with Idris
Elba again another stalker thriller with
a slight romantic edge they also made
the perfect guy that one also had Morris
Chestnut and it was another stalker
obsession themed romantic
thriller and this year Screen Gems has
given us when the bough breaks with
Morris Chestnut another romantic themed
stalker obsession type thriller every
single one of those movies I just told
you about is pg-13 they all have
interchangeable cast members that have
gone into each one of them and every
single one of them except for obsessed
came out in September Screen Gems knows
what they're doing when the bough breaks
is a conveyor belt movie churned out by
your studio that may as well be a
machine assembling all of the products
in the perfect place to hopefully make a
box-office return and that's it
Morris Chestnut and Regina Hall are both
actors far more talented in this
material and I would love to see them
take roles better than this it's so
blatant in its ripoff a fatal attraction
that the actress who eventually goes
crazy her way of going crazy is changing
her hairstyle that's her big character
arc I mean that's what happens in these
crazy movies someone looks all nice and
wonderful and great and you love them
and then all of a sudden they just get
really big poofy curly hair and I guess
they're nuts now my god I'm gonna give
when the bough breaks and f I would love
to not give it an F simply because of
the fact that these actors are talented
but this entire film just reeks of a
bunch of people who are making money and
I really can't forgive that you guys are
the best thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to this Sundays
I'm going to be posting my review of
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
thinks once again and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]